do you want to build a snowman today's
recipe comes to us from the 1958 Good
Housekeeping 10 p.m. cookbook
Vicks cream cheese with Rochefort till
blended
stir in caraway seeds
cut three 16 inch pieces waxed paper
place some cheese mixture and center of
each making one large one medium and one
small mound gathered together four ends
of waxed paper of one mound and twist
forming ball of cheese
repeat with second and third mounds
refrigerate
I'll balls on top of each other to form
snowman use old clothes for eyes nose
mouth to carrot sticks for arms top with
hat made by setting n slice of dill
pickle on center slice serve and enjoy
all right so first things first if we're
going to talk about a problem with this
thing if we're going to talk about a
problem with this recipe it this
produces over a pound of mixed cream
cheese
now conceptually the idea that it's like
oh well you're just you're really just
taking you're just creating your own
flavored cream cheese you know same as a
few mixed in strawberries or whatever
except in this case you've chosen
Roquefort so you end up with Rockford
cream cheese you end up with over a
pound a pound in a corner of Rockford
cream cheese we actually end up with a
little bit more that because it's a it's
a four to one basically just four to one
right ratio and we did it in grams for
for ease because you can get a 500 gram
block of cream cheese so that 125 grams
of Rockford cheese and oh man now-now
Rockford I actually kind of I like
Rockford cheese but the thing to keep in
mind is that it's it's a goat cheese
it's a blue cheese and it's a very salty
cheese so in terms of in terms of sort
of potent flavors Rockford is up there
it's it's not super popular like I it's
the it's the Enter the Void of cheese's
you know people have actually heard of
it
you know you maybe know someone who
actually like enjoys it but it's not
even necessarily something that you
engage with for enjoyment like you don't
you don't eat Rochefort for fun
you eat it for sort of this complex
experience because it's it's not
entirely Pleasant so to create just this
huge pile of Rockford flavored anything
is is really kind of weird and the a the
notion that this is going to be served
for a just kind of a party is is almost
ludicrous if you served this for like a
party of like 200 people 300 people like
this would be more than enough because
it's so potent that when you're putting
it on like crackers and stuff like that
you're not you're not taking like giant
chunks of it you're you're you're
literally just smearing it on there for
for flavor like it's that potent so this
one just why why would you create this
why would you make that much blue cheese
flavored cream cheese and then mold it
into a snowman a pound and a quarter
it's you could maybe this one maybe go
ahead and make in Ian just fractions
fractions of the amount just tiny little
mats like the the head I wouldn't I
wouldn't even make that head worth of
this stuff and that would be more than
enough for for a party you know it would
be it's it's an okay little thing but
just the the volume of it so the concept
is is pretty flawed also this was really
hard to mix it's it's really stiff it's
really sticky and the volume does not
helpful that like makes that way worse
so I would actually make this I would go
ahead and make this in in far far
smaller quantities like I wouldn't even
make 125 grams total of this and that
would probably be in be an okay amount
so if you went with you know 25 75 grams
yeah
but otherwise just
it's so much it's so much